I won't be offline all the time when the  Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards airs  tomorrow night dancer singer social  media sensation Jojo see what is that a  perform we drop by rehearsal to see what  Jojo has in store for us take a look as  we say good night  bye everybody I'm gonna actually be  performing a mix of all three of my  songs kidney cancer all the drama and  boomerang is so good  the 14 year old is nominated for  favorite musical YouTube creator her  videos have more than 1.2 billion views  and the former Dance Moms star is hoping  to get slime I just wanted to be like  the biggest signing ever if I got like a  baby signing that I'd be sad but if it  was like Nuge I'd just be so happy  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]